[Captions by Y Translator]
In today's video,
we're taking a look at
how to make a DIY sandblaster
that you can use to etch
glass, mark steel,
or engrave wood.
[Music]
Hi guys, I'm Nate.
I'm Calli.
And today, we've got
a pretty cool project.
So sandblasters are thing
that take high pressure air,
and drops sand
into the air stream,
and so the sand gets blasted
out at high speeds,
and the sand is really hard.
It's usually made
of things like quartz,
and so those are very good
at etching pretty much anything.
You can carve into steel,
you can carve in a glass,
you can carve into wood.
Unfortunately,
sometimes sandblasters
can be pretty pricey.
Today, we're showing you
how to cut that down
to about five or six dollars,
and just a few tools.
And from what you've
explained to me,
sand can be incredibly abrasive
and sometimes scratch areas
that you don't want scratch.
So what are the other supplies
that were using?
Well, in addition
to the sandblaster itself,
we're going to show you how to
do some DIY masking techniques.
Sometimes using materials
as simple as duct tape.
I'm also going to warn you
that this project does require
owning an air compressor.
So we've got a large
air compressor with a big tank,
and that's what
we're going to be using.
But everything other
than the compressor
itself is very cheap
and easy to get.
The idea is pretty simple.
A drink bottle will
be filled with sand,
which will feed into a hole
that we're going to add
into our air gun.
The sand will be pushed
out by air at high speeds,
and carve into whatever
we're pointing it at.
To start off,
the main thing that we're going
to need is this airgun.
Now, I got this one
at Harbor Freight.
It cost five dollars,
and it's already
a pretty good start.
We just need to make
one quick modification to it,
and then we'll be ready
to start using it.
Do you guys know
what sound does semi-automatic
meow-chine gun makes me?
Here, our airgun is actually
attached to our hose,
and so we can spray air
out of it nicely.
Now, we need to modify it
so it actually shoots
sand instead of air,
and of course,
once there's sand in it,
never ever pointed at a person.
Air is negotiable.
Calli's making quick work
of the drink bottle.
We need this bottle empty,
and then we'll rinse
it and dry it out.
Our bottle is now empty
and dried out.
I'm just going to take
an exacto knife,
and I'm going to cut
this little ring off.
Now if we put the cap on,
we can see that between
the cap and this lip,
there is enough space
for the air gun nozzle to fit,
and that's exactly
where we want to drill a hole.
With this particular nozzle,
we're using a 3/16
inch drill bit.
[Music]
There we go.
We can see that the bottle
now fits onto the end.
But before we put
it on all the way,
we actually need to do
a little bit more modification.
We need to make sure
that the sand is going
to feed into this,
just the way we want.
What we need to do now
is take a file and cut
a small rectangular hole
into the metal tube,
and that's what the sand
is going to feed into.
Our bottle will be attached
upside down with the cap
on full of sand,
but we're not just going
to cut a hole in the tops
so the sand falls in,
we actually don't want
that much sand going in.
What we want to do is cut a hole
in the bottom of the tube
so that the sand is drawn in
by the force of air passing by.
There we go.
We've now carved a hole down
into that metal tube.
And as you can see,
it's on the bottom,
so all the sand will feed down
through the bottle,
and get pulled in by the air
rushing through the tube.
Now we've got
our plastic bottle,
and if you look at the bottom,
you can see the hole that we
carved into the metal tube.
And at this point,
we are just about ready
to fill this thing up with sand
and give it a little test.
We're going to take a look
at the two types of sand
that we're going
to be trying out,
and I got to say,
I've used both
of these before,
and they do both work.
So first we just
have playground sand.
This is about the cheapest
stuff you can get,
I think it's like three dollars
and fifty cents for a bag of it.
It's--
I mean, it's just what you think
of when you think of sand.
This is industrial quartz sand.
It's all pretty uniform in size,
which is pretty nice.
And this is actually
my favorite stuff to use.
Now, like I said,
you can use the playground sand,
but sometimes,
there are larger little rocks
and bits in it.
So if you're going to use it,
I recommend running it
through a sieve or strainer,
and just save all
of the finer grit sand.
Everything that comes
through the sieve,
you should be just fine to use.
But the reason that we want
to do this is these larger rocks
won't always fit
through the hole
that we carved into the bottom
of the metal tube,
and they can get in there
and then jam it up, and then
your whole thing will get stuck,
and it's pretty hard
to clean out.
So you definitely want to run it
through a sieve
if you're going to be using
the playground sand.
This sand, it
really doesn't matter
because as I said,
it's pretty much
all the same size.
There might be
some larger grains,
but for the most part,
you can see it all just goes
right through the sieve.
I'm just going to take some
of this quarzt sand,
and fill our
bottle about halfway.
So right now,
it's just shooting out air.
The sand isn't going
to get to the gun.
But if I turn this upside down,
it now can start feeding
the sand into the gun.
When it's under high pressure,
you can't really
see it very well.
I mean obviously,
you can see it some,
and I'm turning it upside down
because if it gets
too low of pressure,
then all of the sand
gets sprayed out.
It's kind of wasteful
on the sand,
so usually, I'm spraying--
I just like to turn
it over before I stop
so I don't just have
a lot of wasted sand.
This sand is really sharp
and really hard,
and it's going to be moving
very quickly and bouncing back
toward me off of whatever
it is I'm sandblasting,
so I need to have a lot of
personal protection equipment.
I'm not just gonna use glasses,
but I'm actually going to use
this full face mask, and then,
while I'm using sand in this,
I'm also going to be
using a respirator,
because of the sand can break
and create dust,
and I don't want to be
breathing any of that in.
We're not using
a sand blasting cabinet here.
It's just out in the open,
so I'm going to have
a respirator as well
as the facemask,
and I'm going to be wearing
thick leather gloves.
[Music]
You can see how much that sand
has really marked up the glass.
This is permanent.
This isn't something
that's going to wash off.
The sand actually chipped away
tiny tiny bits of the glass,
leaving the surface
rough like this.
Something you can absolutely
feel as well as see.
This just feels kind of
like a rough sandpaper
or ceramic at this point.
It's unlikely that
most people are going
to want to put a freehand
random design onto a cup.
So now we're going
to take a look at
how we can make a mask for this,
and it's pretty simple.
It just involves duct tape.
We've now taken the duct tape
and we've masked off
pretty much the whole cup,
which is just what we want,
because now, we can cut
the design that we like
out of this part here,
and only that part
will get engraved.
How you make
your mask is up to you.
We're just using some paper,
some duct tape,
and exacto knives.
If you have access
to a vinyl cutter,
you might be able to make
some pretty fancy designs.
[Music]
Using a sandblaster
on wood can create a really
cool-looking effect that
you've probably seen before,
without even really
knowing what it was.
When you mask off
your letters or design,
and then sandblast the rest,
it really brings out
the grain of the wood
because the softer parts of the
would get eaten away faster,
and the harder parts
in the grain stay behind.
There are a few things we
need to change however.
The wood, while softer
is also much bouncier,
and it has a harder time
being eaten away the same way
that the glass and the metal do.
So we need to turn
up the pressure
on our sandblaster
by quite a bit.
However, when we do that,
it has a tendency to eat right
through the duct tape,
so we can't use that as a mask.
Instead of the duct tape,
we're going to be using
something much thicker.
This is shower pan liner.
It's designed for going
underneath your shower
in the bathroom to prevent
any humidity or leaked water
from getting into the wood.
It's a pretty thick rubber,
and it comes
in these big whole sheets.
You buy it by the foot.
This whole sheet,
1 foot of it,
was I think about three dollars
and fifty cents,
somewhere around there,
and this is enough
to do a lot with.
To attach this,
we're going to prep
the wood surface by sanding
it nice and smooth,
and then I'm going to use just
some spray adhesive on the back
of our cutout design
on the rubber,
and attach that to the wood.
When your sandblasting wood,
you are going to need
a much higher pressure.
For the glass and steel,
we had it between 20 and 40 PSI.
We want a lot more
than that for the wood.
Now, it's at between 80 and 100 PSI.
[Music]
That's amazing.
To make it a little bit
easier to carve into,
we did use base wood.
That's something you
can just pick up pretty much
any hobby store.
It's not too expensive,
and it does an easier job
of carving all the way
around than some other things.
But this pine 2x4 actually
worked out pretty nicely too.
I really like
how it brought the grain out,
and it's interesting.
It didn't just leave
like stripes in it.
It's actually sort
of a tiered stair-step effect.
What level of difficulty
would you say this project is?
I mean, if you have
an air compressor,
not at all.
This is pretty cool,
and the fact
that you can engrave
and etched glass, steel,
and wood is really neat.
Hey guys, you've probably
noticed that since we introduced
Calli in our Captain
America shield video,
every new video
has had secret codes,
and graphic glitches,
and other secret elements
hidden into it.
Keep track of what you see,
and the timestamps
of when you see it.
We've got some big
prizes to give away,
and finding the codes
might make you our next winner.